I want to talk about
hands down the best remedy to prevent
heart attacks okay and you're going to
be asking yourself why have I not heard
about this before why isn't this in the
news
um well because there's no money in it
that's really the bottom line who's
going to promote it unless they make
money on it no one a bottle of this
remedy which has hardcore scientific
data to show that it can prevent heart
attacks it's only
3.19 okay three bucks so if you say you
can't afford it well I think you can now
I'm going to put a lot of the research
down below one study called the coronary
drug project which was
placebo-controlled use this nutrient
okay to show incredible results but the
remedy is
niacin that's funny because my dad had
heart problems he had a pacemaker had
atrial fibrillation and without my
recommendation he Chows down these
niacin tablets like all day long and he
seems to be doing pretty good but
there's a lot of research on niacin that
goes back decades and you want to get
the niacin that gives you the flush I
would recommend an extended release
niacin at 500 milligrams and do at least
one a day all right so let's talk about
what it can actually do it's
significantly lowers your cholesterol
specifically
oxidized LDL okay that's the type that
creates inflammation it has potent
cardiovascular protection it has been
found to lower the white blood cell
reaction in the inside of your arteries
because when your body is forming a
plaque in atherosclerosis you have an
immune part of that as well that is
usually responsible for inflammation
which we we don't want a lot of
inflammation in Our arteries well niacin
decreases monocytes and other white
blood cells and the inflammation that
comes along with it niacin significantly
lowers something called CRP C reactive
protein C-reactive protein is a strong
predictor of mortality cerect protein is
a very strong independent predictor of
heart attacks or you can call them
myocardial infarction peripheral
vascular disease and stroke if there's
high levels of C-reactive protein in
your body you have inflammation okay and
niacin can help squash that you see when
a clot forms or plaque forms in the
arteries you always have first this
oxidation going on
well guess what niacin suppresses that
oxidation it acts as a very powerful
antioxidant as one of the things it can
do and I think the biggest thing why
it's so powerful is it gets rid of
vascular inflammation and it prevents
the lipids or the fats from depositing
on the arterial wall it also reduces
triglycerides too and at the same time
it increases the HDL so niacin has the
power to slow and reverse arterial
sclerosis and I know you're wondering
why haven't I heard about this why isn't
this promoted all over the place well
like I said there's no money in it
niacin can decrease the mortality risk
in people that have cardiovascular
disease niacin tends to prevent
dysfunction in that inner layer of the
artery called the endothelial layer
which is where it all starts and it
significantly reduces the adhesions that
form in that wall now on the flip side a
lot of people that of high cholesterol
are taking statins so let's just kind of
touch on that while we're on the topic
so it is true that statins do block and
lower cholesterol okay but
there's no evidence that it reduces the
risk of getting heart attacks but
basically statins work by blocking your
body's production of cholesterol the
problem with that is that to make bile
salts you need cholesterol and without
bile salts you can't now absorb vitamin
A D E which is very very important K1 K2
which is another vitamin that's very
very important keeping the calcium out
of the arteries also you need the
cholesterol to make testosterone so a
lot of people are on statins end up with
very low testosterone you know there's
actually no long-term
placebo-controlled Statin trials I guess
they can't do them in humans so it's a
big unknown whether statins really
increase your life or not but we do know
they have a lot of side effects
especially to anything related to your
muscles they block something called
coenzyme Q10 that the mitochondria needs
within your muscle cells and your heart
is a muscle and so some of the side
effects are muscle wasting okay heart
failure all sorts of achiness in your
muscles including low back pain and and
other types of pains so I'm not telling
you to get off your statins all I'm
telling you is to research get the data
show this data to your doctor I'll put
the links down below an informed
decision based on the data versus the
general consensus of what everyone's
recommending so if you're concerned
about your heart and you have heart
issues and you're on medication for the
heart you may want to consider taking
this niacin it's very very inexpensive
get the extended release 500 milligrams
take at least one per day now if you
have not yet seen my video on the best
meal
to protect your heart I put that up
right here check it out